moi je pense que déjà c'est une fausse
polémique le hashtag le hashtag c'est
pas drapeau français ou bleu blanc rouge
le hashtag saana ce exhiberait migration
minutes ça swiss arms et moi série je
suis d'une tradition de la gauche
révolutionnaire enfin pourquoi on va pas
faire un hashtag demain mais tu atelier
art award est l' immigration trouvait la
crise et que tu veux être président des
français président de la free mais
simplement sedan dans les meetings de la
gauche révolutionnaire c'est pas anaska
zip qui a institué ça c'est à dire dans
les drapeaux le drapeau des
révolutionnaires c'est le drapeau rouge
parce qu'on s'a l'vé nuit pour mettre le
drapeau français en fait au drapeau
d'une patrie le drapeau rouge pour nous
c'est le drapeau des travailleurs c'est
le drapeau des communards et c'est un
drapeau internationale mais là tu te
présenter aux élections présidentielles
de plus raccord drapeau rouge pour
montrer ton côté révolutionnaire mais tu
peux aussi de mettre le drapeau français
bon ben voila je voulais y arriver les
actionnaires mais je veux être également
le président des français et c'est vrai
que derrière chacun a eu sur hashtag je
te dis que je ne pourrais m'en passer au
sun pas du tout aux migrations à nask a
dit ben non ça s'est passé est
inadmissible voilà je te le dis mais
c'est vrai que je pense que tu aurais dû
je te promets moi je n'ai pas de conseil
à donner mais avec toi si t'es mis le
drapeau rouge et drapeau français je
pense que vous en pensez lundi je trouve
qu'il y ait des chronographes ont cessé
mais si blanche ça c'est une ambiguïté
c'est à dire est ce que vous êtes un
démocrate en fait
parce que vous apprenez la révolution
vous prenez la révolution c'est pas une
c'est pas une révolution de velours
c'est souvent une révolution violente en
fait vous avez une sorte de violence
légitime dans tout ce que dans toutes
vos prises de position et moi je voulais
savoir aujourd'hui si vous êtes un vrai
démocrate moi je pense que ce que vous
dites zemmour vous diaboliser zemmour ça
me va très bien moi je pense qu'il faut
absolument combattre les idées de
zemmour et non pas le diaboliser
aujourd'hui zemmour c'est 30% et
l'extrême gauche ce que poutou samedi 16
mai avec marine le pen l'extrême honneur
qu'on va dépasser 30% il extrême gauche
encore extrême extrême gauche c'est
poutou ses interviews 5% en fait vous
êtes vous est moribond donc évidemment
vous attaquent à zemmour et c'est
légitime mais en fait vous êtes un
habile orateur comme lui mais vous vous
n'êtes pas démocrate pour moi bah
écoutez je sais pas si vous trouvez une
seule parole en fête qui vous paraît pas
démocrate on voulait rentrer dans le
chou mais moi je suis nous les
entraînons l'elysée moi j'ai acheté une
révolution violent moi vous m'avez
entendu déjà dire ça l'a promis juste
point par point s'il vous plaît la
première chose c'est que à la différence
d'eric zemmour et à la grande différence
c'est que guérir moore est condamné pour
haine raciale et une religieuse d'accord
ces news également été condamné à plus
de 200000 euros damende moi j'ai été aux
grandes gueules je me suis fait virer
des grandes gueules d'accord parce que
on ne disait notamment que je faisais
grève et que c'est un militant de la
maintenant attendez une seconde parce
que c'est trop facile en fait de même
été viré pour ça
s'est mal passé les galets y avait eu
une délocalisation à béziers un baiser
ou
avait cautionné vous avez trop mangé le
matos youn et vous écouterez écouter
arrêtant juste sur ce sujet là vous re
écouterez un reportage sur arrêt sur
image qui reprend l'intégralité des
extraits à aucun moment je n'ai ni
cautionner ni condamné ni quoi que ce
soit j'ai dû être là la fête d'été vous
vous cautionnez ou pas avec des hommes
encagoulés votre exploit il ya aucune
cagoule dans la cfdt je suis venu à
londres non mais excusez moi et
suffisait aux blessures la violence ou
pas excusez moi une révolution calme en
jeu se veulent où on in jusqu'à demain
pour la violence pas pour la violence
les révolutions elles ont été
systématiquement violente et sanguinaire
pour avoir c'est parce que c'est la
contre-révolution qui est sanguinaire et
qui est violente ce sont pas les
communards pour reprendre l'exemple de
la commune de paris se sont pas les
communards qui ont massacré les
versailles et ce sont les versailles et
qui ont massacré les communes à de
l'histoire on a toujours
systématiquement c'est toujours le
pouvoir qui a réprimé massivement en est
aux 60 ans du 17 octobre 1961
on a jeté des algériens par dessus les
ponts de la seine on les a assassinés
c'était c'était quoi ça c'était c'était
une démocratie que les apps yoplait donc
j'espère aujourd'hui
mais moi j'ai maintenant mais c'est vrai
quoi je suis violent et plus d'un et sur
le sujet qu'on intéresse y intéresser le
paquebot
france est ce que vous comprenez qu'il
met pas un moment mais c'est de là
qu'est partie la polémique m et je suis
hashtag remis gracias quasi donc restons
sur le sujet on n'est pas voilà merci
gilbert des sur le drapeau français avec
tout le respect que j'ai pour vous c'est
une énorme faute c'est une erreur grave
c'est à dire que vous vous maintenez
dans une sorte de logique de tout petits
groupes comme ça en excluant tous les
gens qui peuvent parfois avoir envie de
vous entendre ou partager certaines de
vos idées où vous trouver légitime et
qu'il a sont exclues parce que la vision
que j'ai moi de vous c'est vous n'aimez
pas la france en rejetant le drapeau
français je vous le dis très franchement
vous m'avez énormément déçu je suis très
en colère et à la marseillaise
avant la marche est de 6000
le national doit vous voulez vous
présenter alors c'est très bien c'est
une chose depuis en a certains qui
voient tron certains c'est très bien
comme anastasie comme vous les montrez
votre drapeau rouge soyez le président
des révolutionnaires alors ne soyez pas
le président de la france parce que la
france est aussi des emblèmes qu'il faut
respecter ben non on a on assume déjà
très clairement d'être de faire une
candidature qui sont une candidature
révolutionnaire de la jeunesse des
travailleurs des quartiers populaires
d'accord je suis pas là pour représenter
les gens qui vous qui sont du patronat
ou qui sont de la droite libérale ou des
gens qui sont racistes xénophobes
d'accord donc chatte ils ont leur
candidat ils peuvent aller voter mais
vous allez représenter de jeu repris
leurs grilles d'un non je représente
avant tout déjà un camp aujourd'hui je
représente le camp des exploités et des
opprimés je le dis et je le répète une
dernière fois c'est une fausse polémique
c'est à dire que ça fait plus entendre
je suis confiant ça
fait plus de 50 ans vous regardez
l'ensemble l'ensemble des meetings de la
gauche révolutionnaire lutte ouvrière la
lcr le npa il n'y a pas un drapeau
français nommé marcel la marseillaise
c'est devant sony cédant si votre chance
et l'honneur national mais ça change
rien c'est ça change rien aux moines à
changer tout humaine précise en dépit du
tout
pourquoi on en importe on ne porte pas
les faiblesses les bleus blancs rouges
et parfois mais sur laquelle pourquoi
ils ne portent pas c'est ce que ce
drapeau là même s'il a été un drapeau
issu de la révolution il a été entachée
notamment il a été préféré à francis
déterminer s'il est sûr de finir et
donne l'avantagé par l'impérialisme
français ce avec ce drapeau là notamment
qu'on a collaboré avec les nazis c'est
avec ce drapeau là qu'on a colonisé les
grilles
le jeu blanc ils vont finir aussi alors
j'aime bien quand zidane mais deux buts
en finale de la coupe du monde mais la
france ce n'est pas que ça
je suis les français je suis français je
suis petit-fils de tirailleurs marocains
mon grand père qui est décédé de ses
deux des suites d'accords de ses
blessures il avait un éclat d'obus
jusqu'au jusqu'au à autre à l'arrière et
représente même la juge respecté mais je
respecte toi là ne vous agitez pas comme
ça je suis en train de parler de
quelqu'un qui s'est battu
on a dénoncé me dit de vous agiter je
vous parle de mon grand père qui n'en
attendait
pour le drapeau donc j'ai aidé normale
est venu bâtir ici ce pays il est requis
c'est un travailleur marocain qui a
travaillé dans la métallurgie et la sncf
je travaille également je paye des
impôts j'ai le droit de dire que ma
france à moi c'est pas la france de
papon c'est pas la france
amateur nationaliste j'étais vous rien
la salle assez réaliste c'est une fierté
benjamin castaldi canal je vous dis un
truc oui j'avais franchement votre
combat je respecte mais vous avez le
même disque c'est affreux je veux dire à
tous que vous avez le même discours la
même construction que des mots
comme lui parle de charles martel et de
clsa vous vous rendez pas compte et
laval est la noblesse de votre discours
pour le coup évidemment on peut être
qu'on peut que vous osiez oui il faut
que les ans et plus et que c'est un drap
de pas plus rares dans le deuxième le 15
mai votre discours vous grâce à ce que
vous dites vous donner des voix comme ça
à zemmour vous n'aurez le même discours
mais moi je me suis rien du tout mais
pas du tout dans ma carrière non mais
vous n'y allez vous ne pouvez pas aller
honnêtement aujourd'hui avec tout ce qui
se passe avec les autres vous avez en
face ne pas prendre le drapeau français
et ne paraît pas coupable ou pas tu ne
peux pas dire que notre français a été
entaché par map on y revenir
au passé soit regarder devant
vous n'avez besoin dans l'avenir mais
non mais non mais non qu'on a le droit
d'avoir une autre lecture face je sais
me benjamin
castaldi si vous vous êtes prêt à tomber
en fait dans un piège de l'extrême
droite c'est à dire je le dis je le
répète le hashtag ce n'est pas est ce
qu'il faut des drapeaux français ou quoi
que ce soit le hashtag ces annonces
quasi premier migration des clients
légers gala national unique alexis
carrel à sarcelles dans le val d'oise on
veut me faire immigrés ou pourquoi en
fait on est au rendez vous prenez me
touchent la corse
regardez les meetings de jean luc
mélenchon avant que avant la france
insoumise et c'est au moment du front de
gauche y à l'international et m'aidera
pour français mais ça tout je vais
frapper fort ces matches où je
suis à toi mais mathieu un pc un drapeau
est ce que ça veut dire que du coup si
vous étiez élu votre vision à la fois
dire que si vous étiez élu vous
changeriez pas la constitution mais vous
changerez le drapeau français mais
pourquoi en fait vous attacher sur eux
avec vous c'est un symbole pour changer
ce que vous aimeriez changer drapeau
plus haut responsable à franges que vous
aimez je peux le répéter une énième fois
si vous voulez l'entendre d'accord le
nôtre notre problème ce n'est pas celui
du drapeau français d'accord la personne
a posé la question je vois pas c'est
déjà une personne qui quand je clique
sur son nom y écrit hashtag zemmour 2022
dont vous inquiétez pas c'est pas des
lapins de six semaines non plus ils
savent très bien que dans les meetings
de la gauche révolutionnaire il y avait
le meeting d'un camarade qui est philip
poole et pourrait-on époque émissions où
je suis en train de vous remercier
vous aimez la gauche
oui vous poser cette question et je me
fous
du maghreb est
tombé du toit
souple est le problème c'est la maison
du bleu blanc l'installation du travail
qu'il a pris soin d'attacher vous êtes
vous vous
êtes rendu compte qu'ils avaient fait
une grosse connerie ya une france voilà
ce que voulait être président des
français il faut que vous mettiez
français vous mettiez le drapeau rouge
avec est normal mais est-ce que vous
avez deux mètres lors du prochain
meeting jamais on verra drapeau rouge
comme vous l'avez dit on mais l'info
bleu blanc rouge on met pas de drapeau
bleu blanc rouge dans
les gens les gens il n'ya pas de
marseillais je le dis et je le répète
une teigne m feu rouge de france edf
était pour moi j'arrête pas la france le
drapeau des révolutionnaires
sans pêche de vous et moi bah je sais
pas les symboles moi j'aime le train
selon suis très fier avait entendu la
vidéo qu'est ce que je dis dans la vidéo
je revendique tout le passé en fait de
la limite et saint michel mais je
continue
qui me ressemble et j'ai le temps de le
laisser aller représenter un pays et
quand on représente un pays aussi on
représente son histoire une fois on est
fier de ce prix record et les symboles
de la région mais avoue que je suis pas
fier de 2,9 et la france comme on dit
crée pas le maréchal pétain comme
mais littérale générale cédait au point
fort c'est une démocratie puisque vous
êtes là bah oui
je comprends pas le rapport entre nous
entre vous mètres de là vous comprenez
pas qu'on ait une vraie démocratie et
c'est le vote ça justifie le fait que
vous soyez là moi je vois
les révélations du rapport mais parce
que vous vous dites ce que vous dites
c'est une démocratie bourgeoise le
drapeau rouge l'a fait le symbole le
drapeau bleu blanc rouge il s'est fait
avec quoi la méfaits dans la dans la
soirée la nominée
mais gmail et gilet jaune qu'ils ont
manifesté pour déroulement j'ai fait des
câlins avec l'arrivée des débats levée
des
couleurs de la france à tuer moi je
trouve je tâte ananas à l'âge de 11 ans
juste que votre lecture de la france
elle omet l'entièreté de tout passé
révolutionnaire a dit retour en france
est de tous les combats en fait d'être
heureuse des travers je suis celle qui
se sont sacrifiés je le dis ma france
n'est pas celle des rois des bureaux et
des pépins ma france c'est celle de tous
les travaux des travers qui se lève au
quotidien chaque matin et de tous nos
anciens en fait qui se son combat qui
ont combattu qu'on te l'ensemble des
fassis qui se sont combattus ans qui ont
combattu pour les râleurs aller au bout
les acquis sont allés au bout et je veux
aller au bout et dès que je veux changer
le drapeau ki
moon et je voulais mais je m'en fiche du
drame au moins j'ai envie d'augmenter
les salaires jean vient défier le temps
de travail
c'est comme si vous disiez monsieur
regardons je suis animateur sur ces 8
mais jamais je mettrai le logo et jamais
je revendiquerai parce que je déteste
cette chaîne alors qu'est-ce qu'il vous
connaissez vous est ce que je veux dire
j'aime pas son passé qu'est ce que vous
faites la beauté brasseur vous me dites
non c'est pas parce que là c'est le
comprendre monsieur pourquoi que si vous
n'aimez pas vous détailler ici ça vous
suffit pas
et vous n'aimez pas ce drapeau parce que
vous n'aimez pas le passé de l'afrique
jet ski qui porte le drapeau rouge ou
parlant même sujet d'alarmé vous êtes
lassés des candidats vous n'aimez
s'ébaucher tout l'idée l'idée derrière
cette unir quoi c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
fait pas du coup est-ce qu'on change le
drapeau pour proposer une nouvelle
france qu'est ce que vous proposez après
si vous n'aimez pas drapeau qu'est-ce
qu'est ce que vous payez demandé
l'échangé mois mathieu soit lecture elle
est excusez moi et moi je veux m'arrêter
là-dessus sur ce sujet là ok parce que
ces 6 patients l'autre sujet truc on
passe de quelqu'un il ya aucun d'entre
vous la cape honda n'est le fait que
j'ai sur le conte a laissé trop de jus
mais regarde à son compte à dire que
c'est ici que j'ai été en gt en top
tendance anaska zimri migration de 15
heures je sais à 3h05 matin d'accord
avec beaucoup de menaces de mort né et
des méchas bellamy léchage des gueulards
biais de menaces de mort de gens qui je
vous le dire vous prenez surtout les
partisans de la nasse quasi mais je mets
au défi l'ensemble des gens et des
téléspectateurs et des personnes qui
sont autour de cette table prenez une
seule fois trouvé moi quelqu'un où il ya
écrit anaska zip 2022 dans son compte
twitter ou qui portent la photo de la
nasse quasi mais qui menacent des gens
ne m'en fais pas moins seul la noché
regard des filles j'ai regardé à
l'assaut de la ville 300 messages de
gens qui ont la photo dit moore avec un
sniper en train de viser des jeunes
allaient avec écrit ces membranes à ceux
qui nient la raison janot il a aidé me
frenière il a raison la tienne 20
minutes il a raison la jamésie moi
j'avais dit que je n'aimais pas parce
que c'était que les salons des musées
monuments international et vous générez
analyser la question